determina el conjugado de 75 y resulta
que encontrar el conjugado complejo de
un número es facilísimo lo único que
tenemos que hacer es copiar la parte
real aquí la parte real de 7 entonces
seria 7 y a la parte imaginaria le
cambiamos el signo como esto es menos 5
y sería más más 5 y listo ya tenemos
nuestro conjugado de 7 menos 5 y ahora
ya que esto fue tan fácil déjame
contarte otras cosas la anotación para
el conjugado complejo de un número es la
siguiente podemos escribir que 7 que 7
menos 5 y conjugado y se pone una
barrita aquí arriba es igual a 7 5 y hay
otra forma más de describirlo
también se puede poner que z es igual a
7 menos 5 y y entonces utilizando esta
letra tenemos que z conjugado es igual a
7 + 5 y es básicamente lo mismo si y
bueno en realidad
notaciones y encontrarlo es muy fácil
pero quizás una cosa un poco más
interesante es para qué sirve y resulta
que el uso más frecuente de los
conjugados es que si multiplicamos un
número por su conjugado entonces siempre
nos queda un número real cuando
multiplicamos números conjugados nos
queda real
y digo números conjugados porque pues
claramente si 75 y es el conjugado de 7
menos 5 y entonces el conjugado de 75 y
7 menos cinco y si déjame déjame ponerlo
por aquí entonces 77 más 5 y conjugado
es igual a 7 menos 5 y porque
simplemente volvemos a cambiar el signo
de la parte imaginaria verdad bueno
entonces te decía para lo cual es útil
tener los conjugados es porque cuando
multiplicamos los dos números siempre
nos queda un número real déjame hacerlo
en este caso para ver que nos queda
entonces yo digo que si multiplicamos 7
+ 5 y por 7 - 5 y 7 5 y entonces siempre
nos queda un número
entonces vamos a hacer esta
multiplicación la podemos hacer pensando
en la ley distributiva o utilizando esta
técnica que en inglés se llama hoy que
es multiplicar todos los de acá con
todos los de acá con cierto orden pero
bueno vamos a hacer nada más así la
multiplicación distribuyendo vale
entonces 7 por 7 déjame poner otro color
7 por 7 es 49 7 por 7 49 49 luego 7 por
menos 5 y es menos 35 y eso tenemos que
sumarle 5 y por 7 que es más 35 y
finalmente tenemos que hacer 5 y por
menos 5 y hay que tener un poco de
cuidado déjame hacerlo al ladito para
que para que veamos de dónde sale pero
si hacemos 5 y por menos 5 y menos 5 y
entonces el 5 con el 5 nos dan un 25
aquí este menos se queda como menos pero
nos queda una cuadrada una cuadrada y
cuadrada es igual a menos 1 por
definición entonces este menos con este
menos se hace más y aquí nos queda 25
entonces regresando a esta operación hay
que sumar 25 sale sumamos 25 muy bien
entonces qué sucede aquí pues el menos
35 y se cancela con el 35 y finalmente
nos queda 49 más 25 que es igual a 74 un
número real y claro no tuvimos que haber
hecho toda esta lata de multiplicar si
hubiéramos reconocido esto como uno de
los productos notables que es la
diferencia de cuadrados a qué me refiero
a que pudimos haber visto esto como a
más b
por v donde hay 75 y y esta fórmula que
ya vimos antes en álgebra es igual a
cuadrada menos b cuadrada entonces que
nos quedaría en este caso en este caso
bueno nada más te lo voy a contar en
este caso sería 7 b sería 5 y entonces
nos quedaría a cuadrada que es este 49 y
luego menos b cuadrada pero tenemos 5 y
al cuadrado que es 25 y cuadrada que es
menos 25 y con este menos se hace más
entonces nos queda otra vez 49 25 que
suman 74